all right welcome to another edition of
a beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
Hummer today we'll be going over the
most famous game of chess of all time
it's a Paul Morphy against the Duke and
the count all right so he's one guy
against two all right so who do you like
who do you like
all right Paul Morphy was a very good
chess player is born in New Orleans in
the 1830s and he would had really really
good at chess and he decided to travel
over to Europe to take on the best
players and he never got to play for the
world champion chip but uh but and one
time he uh went to an opera enjoying the
Opera and the Duke of Brunswick had a
box right next to the stage there and
he's seen the play so many times he got
bored of it and say hey Paul Moore if
you come over and play me okay so Paul
Morphy played he had the white pieces
and he played against the Duke of
Brunswick and and the Dukes friend count
is 'red okay
so Paul Morphy has the white pieces in
this game so he starts out very common
efore okay is a very attacking player so
they played 'if I've the standard King's
pawn opening white attacks the pawn
Knight f3 and now black plays a very
passive move d6 this is called the
Philidor defense hopefully nobody in the
audience plays the Philidor okay this is
very weak look it already just boxed in
your dark squared Bishop here and a very
passive so when one of your opponent's
is playing passively you want to play
aggressively okay so an aggressive move
here would be d4 attack the center
all right so so blacks should just go
ahead and just take it okay but instead
he decides to get crafty the Duke and
the count they play Bishop to g4 to pin
the night so what they're counting on is
when they take this pawn they'll take
the knight queen will take pawn will
take and everything's looking good right
like we all have the equal number of
pieces but this Queen very dangerous on
f3 targeting the f7 square okay
obviously they're not going to just take
f7 now or else King would take okay so
so what's a way that a white can thread
checkmate in this position yes yeah yeah
yeah you you let's pitch up the c-4
right Bishop c4 it's always good to
attack checkmate thread checkmate okay
so black
they have many ways to to defend it and
they choose Knight to f6 and now okay so
checkmate is off the table but now White
has a very good move here you can
capitalize on this pawn being undefended
and this pawn being very very weak so
what move do we have here for white Jim
Queen to b3 good
so this Queen is attacking the pawn
through an x-ray okay so he's got two
players coming down on f7 and only one
defender Kings can't capture protected
piece and he's taken that okay so
the count in the Duke they're like okay
let's play Queen to e7 will protect the
pawn and then when pile more if he takes
takes on b7 we're going to have a very
good move here how in the world can the
doubt count in the Duke save their rook
Queen to b4 check good he's got to take
take and then you know they're going
upon but they're not going to get
checkmated right now Paul Morphy he saw
this and he wants to watch the play here
okay so he doesn't want a big long
drawn-out game okay
he wants to enjoy himself okay so he
decides I'm not going to take the pawn
because then you know the Queen's are
going to be traded so he's going to play
his knight up to c3 okay so so now so
now black with Queen to e7 they've
stopped
f7 right so now he wants to stop b6 he
also probably doesn't want his this
night getting into b5 or d5 as well so
what's a cool move black can play here
too to protect this pawn and stop this
Knight from advancing c6 good see
discovered discovered protection okay
all right so so a very interesting thing
in this game as you'll see is our good
friend uh Julian pointed out to me in
this game Paul Morphy never moves
backwards he never retreats never
retreats
he's always either moving parallel or
forward okay so keeping that in mind
when you try to look at whites
moves here okay so so look Paul Moyer
was really good at getting all his
pieces off the back row and into the
game okay
so so we got this rook Bishop and other
look that need to play still all right
so who do you think we should get off
the back row and start playing the
bishop okay so bishops their big trick
is pinning pieces okay so Bishop pins
the knight also now his threat is a so
if you like attacks it or something I'll
take if you take back with the Queen I
get your pawn if if I take back my pawns
are just going to be no good okay so so
lots of good threats there just by our
hand pieces so black like he says I have
enough of this I'm playing b5 okay so
now I'm attacking the bishop remember
Paul Morphy he doesn't want to retreat
in the game so notice this pawn
attacking the bishop supported by this
point so he's going to get two pawns for
a minor piece this isn't really
advisable unless you have on some kind
of a good King side attack where you're
attacking the King but this King is in
the center of the board so it might be
advisable to try to just break it open
and keep the pressure on so if you were
going to take this b5 pawn how would you
take it would you would take with the
Queen
the knight or the bishop who votes for
the night who seen this game they all
voted for the night they're all as good
as Paul Morphy all right pawn takes
Knight takes and now will take with the
bishop for the check and so he's already
got one night in a pen they're like
let's put our other night in a pen okay
and now when pieces are in pins its
variant
going to attack them okay you went to
attack pen pieces so knowing that what
do you think POW more if he played we
want to attack the pinned pieces rook d1
what to move just a little bit better
than rook to d1 that also puts our rook
on d1 long Castle okay you might as well
get your Kings safe but the idea is put
your rook on d1
okay so castles okay all right so so now
let's see what black does because he is
neither of his knights can move his
bishop can't move it's not going very
well
he must protect this night so he doesn't
lawn castle he plays rook the d8 okay so
now Paul Morphy sees wow my rook is on
h1 not doing anything right
so he could just put it to e1 but that's
pretty weak right I mean what's he doing
on e1 really just protecting a pawn
so which file do you think he wants this
rook to be on the D file that I mean
this is where all the action is the D
file so he clears out this other rook
okay now he's got to take back with the
rook right because he takes back with
Queen loses Queen takes back with the
night he loses the Queen illegal for him
to take with the king so he's got to
take with the rook right oh wait so we
just sacrifice an exchange but now it
made room for this rook to get the d1
okay and now he's attacking a pin piece
again so now it's really tough for the
count and the Duke to protect this rook
again so they try to get a queen
trade does anybody think that polymorphs
there okay I'll just trade Queens and
and hope no no all right so he doesn't
do that does anybody have any good ideas
this is kind of tough what he does so
it's okay to capture pink pieces right
as we saw earlier if you know if you're
going to get another attacker onto a pin
piece or you know if you calculate it
out
then you're going to win a lot of
material okay so we actually takes
Bishop takes rook with check okay so
obviously if he takes with the Queen the
rooks just going to take right and you
can't take with the King so hey I'll
take with the night okay so so now White
has a good combination here some people
probably already seen it before
but notice in this position what would
happen if this rook could somehow get
the d8 and be checkmate right so so then
you just have to ask yourself why is it
my rook
why can't it go to d8 and you say hey
just Knights blocking it so if if you
could all agree if some way where you
can get the knight out of there
right where you can play rook the DA
checkmate obviously rook takes Knight
doesn't work because hey Queen will take
the rook and then I don't have checkmate
or the King could even take the run
which would be the best move if work
takes knight ok forward so we want to
get our work to da but we can't because
of dumb Knights in the way okay so if
only we could force that night off of d7
we would have checkmate is there any way
we can force this Knight out of here
Queen to b8 check alright the only legal
move black has is Knight takes Queen and
then we just slider rook red up for the
checkmate alright so that is a Paul
Murphy's a famous game he'd be two
people the count and the Duke and it's
also referred to as the opera game
because they were watching an opera at
the time okay so that so that's the
that's the game now a lot of people say
oh Paul Morphy he played great but I'm
going to show you that unfortunately not
a game like Paul Morphy I'm going to
show you how to play like the count and
the Duke okay
there's nobody will ever show you all
right this alright so everybody says
Paul more if you play great but in this
game I have the black pieces and
unfortunately I play like the count and
the Duke so we're going to see if I can
make any improvements on the count and
the Duke good luck
alright so in this game I play my boss
for the Chess Club ladder rank of number
one okay I have the black pieces and I'm
going to play like the count in the Duke
alright so white plays d4
so in in the Murphy game he played efore
so this will transpose I play the move
d6 now white plays d4
and black plays 'if I've I was hoping
that white would take I would take Queen
takes check King takes although this
looks a little odd white is going to be
fine here our black is going to be fine
here because you can't really get get
checked he's just going to get his a
King pawn on c6 King on c7 and his King
will be nice and safe okay but Tony
plays on Knight f3 and so I play it so
this should look very familiar so so if
you watch the last game
what should a white play here so you
guys want to play like Paul Morphy what
would you play you know where did palm
or if you play in the in the Opera game
not quite he takes the pawn right
because if I take back the pawn Queen
takes King takes and now Knight takes
pawn threatening the bishop and I Knight
takes f7 Chuck forking the rook and the
King
okay so pawn takes pawn
so now black has to play Bishop takes
Knight
so Queen takes and now pawn takes and
now we get Bishop to c4 threatening
checkmate okay so so I remembered a
little bit of the count in the Duke game
so I'm like well I'm not going to put my
knight on f6 because that's that's crazy
okay so I'm going to play Queen to f6
which actually isn't much better because
White's going to fall or do the same
thing what did he play in the game at
Queen to b3 threatening here
and here okay
so I don't have a the of the move so I'm
going to go ahead and thread my own
check sorry
all right Bishop to c5 okay all right so
what should Tony play now okay so I just
played Bishop to c5 I'm threatening
Queen takes F to check so now what we
have to do is analyze who has the
stronger threat right like so if I was
playing at home if I was playing white
should be considering Queen takes b7
winning the rook then or should he be
afraid of Queen takes f2 check do you
think if he gets Queen takes F to check
and if he plays that if he plays Queen
takes F to check am I going to have any
kind of a attack all right or is this
going to be worth the rook what do you
think should white play Queen takes b7
and take this variation or should he
just take the coward's way out and just
castle the safety allowing me then to
play Bishop to b6 and stopping all the
shenanigans what would you do if you
were playing white would you go for it
take the pawn okay so what if what if
black plays this move Queen to c6 see
how that that protects the rook through
an x-ray why is that a double question
mark move
you lose the Queen yeah good you lose
the Queen Thank You bishop the b5 and
now the Queen's got no place to go all
right so let's say I went down there and
check King here now what does he do he
could take this pawn maybe do we want to
take his rook or do we want to take make
up all we have to do is move our work
we're going to actually move our rook to
f1 because it's protected by the bishop
huh and then I could take here why one
take there I probably play Knight to f6
to protect it Queen takes castle and now
who do you think's winning white White's
crushing okay so so that's what you want
to do you want to look at your
opponent's threats and say hey you know
you've got nothing all right you can
take f2 because you're taxed going
nowhere I'm going to win a rook okay
unfortunately in this position after I
play Bishop to c5 he thought he saw a
cool a cool check here after Bishop
takes f7 Queen takes and now he plays
Queen to b5 check thinking he's going to
win the bishop
why doesn't he win the bishop yeah that
goes the d7 protects the bishop so now
Tony's in a lot of trouble so so now he
unfortunate I guess he got angry he
should definitely know I still have this
this major threat on right so at this
point he should just you know just
castle and get to safety but and say
takes and now he lets all all this bad
stuff
happened to him rook the d8 put the
knight and the rook in the same same row
as the king and it's going to be tough
for him now Queen takes thee seven when
takes g2 rook to e1 and it's by no fun
to play on a on white side right now
so you just check King to d2 now we
finally get this discovered check in and
things are going going good for for for
black for sure so so actually he's in
such a bad predicament here what would
happen if he would play King to c3 do we
have any kind of a oh well that would
happen yeah we would just take the rook
and it would all be down and so so he
takes King takes and see how white
failed to really develop here so Knight
to c3 it's just too late now Knight to
f6 b4 and it's just essentially a mop-up
time but we still have to watch out for
threats right because just because we're
in mop up time mode doesn't mean like
he's not going to try and crush us
because what did he just play by playing
Bishop to b2 this is when this is like
sometimes people say oh it's so tough to
win a one game because they tend to fall
asleep at the board is like oh I just
play Bishop to b2 whatever out maybe
I'll get my rook out okay but what is he
attacking with Bishop to b2 here
the Queen yep so we better move the
Queen all right Queen to G to rook the
d1 is threatening the discovered check
here so Queen to g5 check King the d3
that's where we wanted we didn't want
them to get safe over here we want to
win as fast as possible here Bishop the
d4 King the c4 King e7 let's our rook
play King the b3 it'll just take take
get a check in here the more we trade
pieces the easier it is going to be for
us to win here d5 Knight to d5 rook
takes d4 protect it and now now he gets
so we can't move our night or he puts
our 19 open or else we'll take our rook
we got the pawn here so c4 okay so we
kind of let them back in the game here
but we try a trick here with a 5 and
fortunately he falls for he plays a 3
here instead of just taking the night
and now when we get a 4 check he's got
to move his king and now what move do we
make just to to basically just end end
the game Knight to c3 check no reason to
play Knight takes b4 check right now we
just begin overnight we're going to play
Knight to c3 check and in this game is
in the bag here rook takes d4 doesn't
matter King takes c3 and rook takes
check
King takes and it's not even worth
watching the end of the game King to d1
and we're just larger King up the board
and there's nothing he can do
don't check them here or else it's not
mate check them here
checkmate okay so that's that okay so so
that's a little improvement on the
account and the Duke game but it's not
advisable to play like them because
because you saw that Tony had a great
chance early on to just take the pawn
and win here so it's not advisable but
here's another game I fall for it again
here
alright so it's very important to to
know what you're doing for move one of
the game okay so so unfortunately I
played like the count Duke not once but
twice okay this is a game from not too
long ago from what was that last one but
to show me classic okay I was playing on
1900 Jonathan who is not here tonight
but but if you're not careful for move
one if you just go in the game just say
odd just through whatever you could end
up playing a bad opening okay so once
again I had the black pieces here and so
white starts out d4 at d6 so now you
should know if your opponent plays d4
don't play d6 okay just just go all the
way d5 because that will stop white from
playing efore okay so D Ford d6 and so
then we got efore here and so this is
very so black plays Bishop to g4 again
okay
so what do you think white does here
tape on your right alright so now I have
to take the bishop Queen takes pawn
takes and what happens bishop here okay
so so once again Queen to F
Queen to b3 okay so now I decide not to
play Bishop to c5 again and because I
figured a it didn't actually threaten
checkmate before so so I play b6 but
look how weak that makes all my light
squares around here okay and see if
white can punish me for doing that so if
you watched Paul Murphy's game right
what did Paul Morphy try to do did he
move a lot of his pieces just around a
lot or did he try to get everybody
involved try to get everybody playing
right so if Paul Moyer was playing this
game he wouldn't like go for the check
or anything you're probably just played
his night up to c3 right like you played
and maybe try to threaten in here maybe
try again here or maybe just try to get
another piece in okay so that's what he
was really big on getting rapid
development and attacks okay but by
playing Bishop to e3 I mean that's kind
of where my bishop wants to go and
what's this really attacking anything
like you almost want to save this bishop
move for a possible a queen deflection
if you can
okay so Bishop to e3 Knight to d7 now
I'm threatening to get my Bishop out
here so now he pins my knight okay but
now I get the move c6 in kind of like
the count in the Duke played c6 and it
was a good move probably their only good
move in the game I get the c6 move in so
Bishop to a6 now all your piece values
are based on how mobile your pieces are
okay by playing Bishop to a6 Black has a
chance to kind of smother him okay so so
if you wanted to try to trap this Bishop
what move would you play
b5 let's say yep b5 okay attacks the
Queen and now this Bishop can't get out
on this diagonal so the Queen only has
one or two moves I guess Queen to a5 all
right so now he put his king and the
Queen in the same diagonal but this
Bishop check doesn't work because he can
just take okay so Bishop the c5
threatening so if he takes back I'm
going to take with the night and now
this Bishop is under attack and then
under pressure okay so white decides
yeah it's time to get castle okay so
castle so now if I take here he'll take
back and you'll see how he'll have a
discovered attack on my queen okay so
even though I want to give them double
pawns and and they're isolated pawns
it's not worth it
because then this work will be bearing
down on my F file okay
so always want to look at the
consequences to your captures okay so I
decide to retreat and attack the Queen
and now the Queen goes back so now all I
have to do is attack this bishop and
he'll be a goner
it's Knight to b8 a good move why is not
b8 a bogus move all right
so Peter says maybe not the right answer
what would you play Jim Bishop the b7
wins the rook okay
so we got to be careful we got to be
careful okay so so now black just tries
to develop normally and get castle
so now white finally gets them off
castle so now so all of whites advantage
from early on are gone because of a
a mistake in the opening instead of just
developing pieces getting castled he
decided to try to to get his Bishop down
here and win the rook when it just
wasn't going to happen so we needed to
calculate that out and see hey there's
no way I can really win this rook so I
shouldn't I shouldn't try that so
White's idea should be to try to free
this bishop how would you go about
trying to free this bishop any ideas
a4 yeah good that that's what he that's
when I would be playing because because
the bishops pretty much useless down
here right so when I say he tries Knight
to b3 rook the d8 he challenges the file
so now Knight to b8 works because he
plays Bishop the b7 which is what he
plays my rooks not attack all right sir
so Rick to d6 he attacks it so take take
so now he's got two attackers on my rook
and I only have one defender do you
think I'm going to take and let them
have the D file no see I want that D
file so how can I keep the D file stack
the rooks good all right rook rook there
that way I'll have the D file if I take
look at what I would have just done even
though it would have been checked that's
all well and good all right check them
but now look now he's got the D file and
he can start punishing me okay so you
never want to give away the files okay
all right so now a lot of things get
traded and at the end of the day I still
have the D file okay so now he needs to
run his King over here so then he can
challenge the file
and King here so now he decides to break
open with a four so he plays I play b4
okay because because if I if I take here
look at how powerful his rook just got
okay attacking the pawn and that pawns a
gun or okay so you never want to open
your files for for your opponent okay so
just pass it up it's a six so now this
is this is a goner there's no way I'm
going to be able to trap the bishop so I
might as well get my knight to play okay
so now the bishops free so he attacks
the pawn so the worst move in all a
chest if you guys have been following
the series maybe Steven knows Peter
Peter might know what what's the worst
move you can always play in chess f6
okay f6 so so I do play the worst move
but there's logic to it okay
so I don't want you to think I'm a
hypocrite or nothing so f6 so notice the
Queen's are off the board
my king isn't castled and on g8 okay f6
by playing f6 this really isn't going to
hurt me okay he's not going to get any
kind of check or pin or discovery my
King's that over there so f6 is fine in
this position because I mean it's the
endgame it'll be okay
so I have six it works in that position
and he counters with f3 f6 is good it
supports this pawn it gets all these
guys in a pawn chain here alright so
King up Knight back the D to rook up
attacks the bishop but it's protected by
the knight pawn place c3 takes takes
and now we pretty much go back and forth
for a while night attacks the rook rook
attacks the pun protects the pond I go
back you challenge just the file I go
back and then we could just be doing
this all day
rook to see one rip back rook here and
it ends in a draw up eventually okay so
so that's that's the that's the game
that's the famous count in the Duke game
so so who do you think had a better
strategy more fee or the count and the
Duke more fee good he wants to get all
his pieces out attacking castle een
developed well the Duke all he did was
Paradis pieces in the pins never really
got any pieces out of his territory so
that's what you have to do and when your
opponent makes mistakes in the opening
by playing really really passive moves
like the Philidor defense or even like
d6g six that's when you really want to
get your pawns out to e4 d for I get
your Knights developed and really put
the pressure on attack that f7 square
because that's the time to strike okay
because they're not striking they're
letting you do whatever you want and
that's what you want to do make sense to
everybody all right fantastic all right
thank you all for coming for another
edition of beginner breakdown